How I described the situation is that is
the opposition,
but is the regime and both are fighting
for the power and that the red line in
Syria is the power the chair.
I don't.
I do not see that the red line is
neither for the opposition,
nor for the regime is the country.
The difference is enormous.
You can the opposition,
they're after power rather the country
now it is.
It is what we say in Arabic,
which means a winning or losing the
power.
So for me,
what I feel is what I.
When I look at the opposition,
I don't feel they represent me.
When I look at the aging,
definitely
presenting and that implies a kind of
equality kind of parity between the two.
Here are these two forces fighting for
power.
Do you think that's right?
Is there a kind of parody between
opposition in government in Syria?
I think who is fighting for the country
who wants to put the country first
rather than the chair rather than
grasping the pallet?
I disagree Turkey with what she said
simply because there is no real
opposition yet that has formed in any
political sense,
and this is very much to do with the
fact that the notion of an opposition
has totally obliterated from Syrian
polity and Syria and life and Syrian
minds.
Um,
what we have seen over the past year and
weeks is the creation of a groundswell
movement that has taken over the whole
of the country.
So it's no longer in humps or in
Adelaide or in other areas in Syria.
It is everywhere in the country.
So this parity,
so called parity simply does not exist.
And the idea that the opposition is
fighting for a chair I think is quite
bizarre to me anyway.
Um,
let's just hear your view of it because
you were there.
Yeah,
I think it's,
it's actually betty,
betty simple at the moment,
the battle in Syria,
the conflict in Syria at the moment,
it boils down to one word,
and that is actually survival,
survival,
survival.
And that's what people are fighting for.
Rob,
at this point in time,
people are fighting to stay alive.
You know,
they every tonight nicer indicated no,
there was no political push from within
Syria.
It's a fight to stay alive day to day.